Oh wow look I'm in space...
Ohh
Wow, I am inside your mom ... 's house
I'm such a genius. I set up this green screen right and I have not just double-layer green shirts
But also these are my only pair
of headphones
Yeah, good job man Wow you're like super smart and stuff
It's gonna look crazy. Whatever okay? Whatever. We're playing evil within
Can't even see anything cuz my mic is like
Clearly I didn't think through this setup
Whatever, okay?
Hey
You remember evil within it's made by legendary horror game maker Shinji Mikami
Who made the Resident Evil series and considering how good the?
Resident Evil 7 was I'm actually really excited about this one see see if that was kind of like catalyst
For the future of triple a horror games which have been so god-awful
For the past couple years. I have a sneeze coming
Home engulfed in flames try to fire kills child nanny. I remember the first game had the story of a like a
Spooky scientist. It's a crazy scientist wow what an original concept of the horror video game
I'm doing I'm doing I do look forward to play this game. I really do because I hear it's actually pretty good
Maybe a potential series you know
Chapter 1 begins
Hate when that happens
just come home from a stroll in the woods, and your house is on fire, but those pants, those pants are on fleek
Shizzle, Lily is in here
Family friendly still
Excuse me Lily
I'm gonna go ahead and say that Lily is done
Ok, I think the game wants me to go this way
"Dammit!"
How about that? I did it
Alright, here we go
Oh God!
Let me guess, she's going to die and therefore the horror character
She just serves as a purpose to make the character have some sort of story how did this happen?
Lily what up dog it's your boy
I'm coming, I'm coming man. Yeah, that's right. He even said it
I can't sprint, but whatever
I don't really know where to go though here. Here? Aw no, that's not gonna do it
Oh I can crouch here, the game will teach me how to crouch now, how about that?
You have to know how to crouch in this game, cause otherwise the spooky
monsters
Lily your house is not even on fire. Yeah come on out, please
Oh my god, she's already dead
Punch her! Literally kick her, she's a devil
It's a trap, it's a fake one
My god
That's pretty cool, I guess
like the classic
storytelling of a guy having guilt
When it clearly wasn't his fault to begin with, but they always have it
Oh, I feel so guilty about this one thing it really haunts me. Great!
Clearly we all saw that it wasn't your fault. It happens all the time in movies. I'm so sick of that way of storytelling
Why am I so critic Jesus Christ what has happened to me.
No, he still feels guilty.
Moebius? Oh my god, did you guys hear did you guys hear? He said Mobius!
wha-
It's the-
Hey now, sit
Sebastian calm down
Hehe, of a child, get it?
Child's play?
Haha
Listen I'm just going to say my daughter. Okay. I don't
You'd think they'd let me sober up first before they did this
Like why was I in a wheelchair?
Heyyy here we go
oh thats cool
Okay
Very cool very cool
No nose hair at all look at that you must be plucking that
Every day
Okay
Alright I control the camera for some reason
The evil withiiin
dos
Cool I'm excited now. Can I play please?
I'm the worst. I'm the worst let's player of all time. Let's get real here. You're watching the wrong channel here
Here we go hey look at that story in setting my where am I people?
Here we go that's the house
Whoa, what the f-
Is that a phone
Could that be her calling us
From the outside that might be pretty cool. you could communicate.
oh my gah
It is her!
Haha yeah shut the fuck up Sebastian
Oh, that's cool.
Aww, it's got a cute-
Yeah, ask yourself
Thank you
Its a cute little kitty cat, hey man
Ha I didn't see it
Does it speak? The cat speaks. I bet you it speaks
Aw, thank you kitty.
What up kitty cat, what did you want?
Don't don't no kitty get away from the jar
Green gel it's gross, and it usually comes from dead enemies
But if you collect that you can use it to obtain increased abilities
Thank You kitty for the green gel. Anytime my man
Anytime my main guy
Save terminal, gotta love my save terminal
Let's do a little let's do a little save there huh I'm playing on the hardest difficulty by the way there, its called game journalist mode
I'll probably change it later. Okay. There are photos of a bunch of your team
Great so your experts need rescuing -
Thanks for the vote of confidence, but I'm only here to find Lily
Okay chat that was chapter 201 okay? I don't know how I did that I investigated
That's how you open a door everyone
Search mobile you search team members within stem for a lead on
Lily. Lilly the frilly as I like patilly
should be a way out I
Couldn't my memory. Just make regular doors came there
uhm ok, mirror mirror, on ze wall.
We go again into the looking this is how you do it correct
It's okay mom can fix it for you she can fix anything
Sebastian what's wrong? Are you alright?
Why does my wife look like a granny, my god, I picked the wrong one --amazingly smart and beautiful wife--
Why wouldn't I be alright?
Come here
I'm looking too hard. It's making you delirious. Are you sure you're not coming down with something
Aaaand we're back in hell, great.
Wow what a good thing that we didn't walk any further
Is this the right place
Well we don't really have many options
I want to get the gun, ohhh cool
That's dope
Isn't his running animation really weird? I guess its the belt?
Okay, lets see if we can fi-, oh that's where we came from, there's a mirror. Are you kidding me? Oh?
They are mind fucking me right now aren't they?
You giving me a little shnitzel
These are locked probably both of them not even gonna bother
Very strange okay, so if we go through the door again
Got a flashlight very nice
Wonderful pictures
Very nice oh
That's not how you chair, stupid chair
What the hell
Whoa hahaha, they should do some slow-mo
I'm guessing I can't interact with it. That's cool. Man. Yo Baker how you do men
Is everything slow-mo for me as well then
The team leader- maybe has something on him- one bullet straight ahead
Wonderful Wow how nice okay am I done here? Yep?
Strange people are very strange these days. You know that reference good on you
Guess we'll check if there's something here --someone tried to block the way out....or in--
Okay potentially escape route for later
Sadistic- we got a file everybody-  whoever did this must have enjoyed it
How is this even possible well, we're in a dream world, so I don't know why you would question that  "how's it possible"?
aaah
that's not a beach its a bathtub
Great... did i just walk in circles?
...i did
This is another library no, it's the same
What are we looking for I don't even know
Is my mission here?
Someone locked the doooor, what an oopsie doopsie
Should we remove this maybe?
Okay
There you go
Very nice, I must be a genius to get through that
How about that
Okay, I guess we're going this way
Just about to say there was a phone before I'm like I'm sure it's gonna ring
Hello, mina-san. It's a pewdiepie desu
Is that all he does?
Good good prank old buddy. Ha ha ha ha ha got you
Shit shit, I'm Sebastian where is my daughter?
Where is she
I'm gonna steal the Declaration of Independence
I'm
Sebastian
shit I
just do the Crouch cuz I'm Sebastian, I collected another file, how about that
extravagant letter
Alright, you can read that if you feel like that's your thing
Can you do a quick turn? Yes, you can camera is not as quick down
Hi
Hey damn it
What's going on here
What is happening here I am Sebastian and there's like something really strange going on in this place. It's really weird
Oh my god, is this game supposed to be a horror game
Well that's cool, it's very visually cool, but like it ain't scary dog
Love the floor very Twin Peaks
Wow he is a bad man, oh he takes picture when he kills people I see
But what's that?
Okay, so we have to be covered hold to enter cover
R1 okay
And then move alongside when near corner icon will be displayed in that direction okay?
So I think we have to move this way right
While he's super scary
Can't seem to move
Who the hell was that alright well, I did it somehow anyway even though I failed amazingly just like the search team
Are you doing there buddy yeah, you're right everybody Oh
Sexual I like that look at that very very nice
Oh my gosh
Ah
You imagine that that's a good way to die just constantly moaning ah
Okay alright, we're here now. I gotta find a way out of here
But you just joined stay a while, I thought we were looking for your whamon
Alright so we checked upstairs
We didn't really check here hasn't because there's nothing there Felix. That's why I have this large sound
spookie I
Can we jump down
Probably should
Whoa whoa, whoa was that a mannequin head
That's awesome
How cool I don't think you guys were hanging here before?
Very nice should we go down here?
All right, I think we want to stay off that guy right I
Can't go up so we gotta go there man. It's getting it's getting more and more intense
Excuse me
Pardon me sir. I'm looking for my daughter. I think you can help no
You can be great help
It's this place supposed to make people happy cuz they ain't doing it for me, man
My god it looks shit on PlayStation look at that
It looks awful
What happened there look at the tape there's no textures?
Christ
Only when I get closer
It's pretty good art design, I do like it
Oh
I thought maybe he would come out all right
Okay, which floor 13
Remember the elevator in Silent Hill
Where it's missing one floor, and then you do the thing and then all the sudden there's an extra floor, and you're like whoa
What the heck man, we're entering a bad place now definitely
No, that's the kind of feeling I miss from a lot of horror games
This seems like a lot of a look it's blood. That's scary, right
Look is that people let's that's scary right hey you guys doing just hanging around
Oh, that's a night, maybe cooler one of them grabs me or some shit
Are they changing
This is worse than the Rick and Morty porno
I'm Audi oh
That can't begin
He's playing with this
What I didn't what a crazy guy
That's crazy, man. What a crazy me?
I'm guessing this is just like the intro. I'm sure the game will pick up its gaming elements instead of having this walking simulator
Is awesome are we gonna run oh, we are oh my god, hahahaha
Brendan consumes stamina, oh well, I think that's not really my biggest issue right now
That's cool
At the cool-looking monster right there
Shame I can't look back because I kind of want to see how she looks like
But I feel like I shouldn't I don't know how to jump ok did it for me, Oh
Excellent that's perfect. Thank you
No, this is just like the first game you have to figure some way I had to escape before timing run sound
Climb climb damage the crazy chainsaw lady will get you aah
Same
Kind of wanted to get killed by her god damn it she looks so cool
Ha ha I was awesome, I really enjoyed that
Hey look. It's a red. Oh my friend. Well. I guess we're not friends. Oh Mike
You killed mr.. Hecht you monster, how could you do this?
Got an answer
Now I know for sure that she's a bad person
But was willing to give the benefit of the doubt for you now oh
I don't hear it. Well. You made a big noise
Jumping down I better be sneaky. Yeah, all right. I can't run or do anything
Oh my gosh, she's so cool
Let's do sprint consumer stamina
So what
big chase my chainsaw guy oh
Shit oh
No, we didn't
All right that can't be good
We're gonna die
We're almost at we're almost at game is doing it for me, that's cool didn't want to play anyway
All right, what the fuck is going on here?
All right, what do you guys think I think it's pretty interesting it seems to be very similar to the first game
but it runs a lot better and
It's very pretty
Let me know if you want me to do more of this. I like will come a long way
I would really appreciate that it really helps me out a lot and just let me know
I probably will play more of this anyway to be honest with you because I do like it so far
Not like super impressed, but you know I'm hoping it will pick up that last part was really cool. Oh
My god, that's it for me for now
*brofist*